let's uh we actually have a story to
talk about in with kids and stuff we
have this from the new york times
it is uh how a debut graphic memoir
became the most banned book in the
country crazy maya kobabi's book
genderqueer about coming out as a
non-binary landed the author at the
center of a battle over which books
belong in schools and who gets to make
the decision so i don't know if you
could pull that up and we can show the
uh the image
can we
what it's just yeah it's just the
article from new york times okay yeah
yeah so the issue here is the new york
times
won't actually show you what's in the
book
right because what actually got this
book
banned from libraries is
sexually graphic images and the books
directed at minors
i
i can only describe it that way if i
were to actually say
what the book showed
then parents would probably be upset
which i can respect but youtube
absolutely would give us a flag a
million percent well so what will happen
is when the show's over
we'll go and it'll it'll give us the
yellow demonetization thing then we got
to request it
if i describe to you the images in the
book because they're sexually graphic we
will get confirmed demonetized and the
clip from the show will also be
demonetized and
you could potentially youtube will
punish you with with down ranking
so these days in the past where they
would apply codes to your channel which
would make it harder for like shadow
banning basically yeah
if i tell you what's in the book
and this book showing sexually graphic
images was being put in school libraries
and when people complain about it the
new york times
defends the book doesn't show any of the
images why could you imagine what would
happen to the new york times if they
showed these these graphic images it's
it's it's people doing things it is cart
cartoon images drawn of the author uh by
the author showing people engaging in
activities we'll call it that it's young
people though isn't it yes one of its
yeah one of one depicts miners oh my god
one of the images i think they both
might depict minors what makes this the
most banned book
like what is the
uh think about what they're saying with
this
a book with sexually graphic materials
was in a children's school library got
removed it's the most banned the book
yeah well hustler is not allowed in the
school library yeah hustler's definitely
more of a banned book yeah better
articles too oh well hustler was never
put in and then banned so terrifically
it wasn't right right technically yeah
no
it was always banned yeah yeah it's just
started out bad it was never allowed
so so where where is the line and this
is why i think when it comes to left and
right
there's it's just literally tribe it's
like
do you bend the knee to what the left is
because if a kid walked into a grade
school with a hustler the teachers would
freak out if a kid walks in with this
book
well it's educational well it's not just
the kid walking in with it it's the
teacher walking in with it and showing
it to the kids
right to you yeah no i'm serious they
should be in prison yeah
that should i mean you are a danger to
society and you're a danger to children
if you're showing them pornographic
images yes that's it hustler for
instance is nudity this is actual sex
this book is showing it's cartoon sex
but it's sexuality that's a little
different thing are the people depicted
are they actually depicting minors and
these cartoon images in these drawings
they're just pretty sure
the most notorious image from this which
depicts an adult activity between two
people is um they're minors
i'm pretty sure the point if you can't
tell yeah if you can't tell you've got
to err on the side of yes they're a
minor it's called lolly you know you
can't you can't mess with cartoons of
young looking but look at this look at
this this woman here they're like they
took the new york time gets this woman
to come out her name is mandy zhang of
wappinger's fall new york is planning to
start a band book club hey all right we
can show up and bring playboy with us
because that's not a lot in schools
either right this is the fascinating
thing to me because i hear this argument
from the left where they're like they're
trying to ban books and i'm like there
are tons of books that are legitimately
banned from these schools when they talk
about you know wanting to ban critical
race theory books just as a blanket
statement i can't remember who we had on
the show but i was like i don't want to
do that i think schools depending on the
age should critically
discuss what this book is my issue is
when they inject the ideology into their
classes without telling you what they're
teaching you is the praxis of critical
race theory what about having i don't
know i don't want books banned but
here's my point
it's not a banned book club to bring
porn you're you're like these these
books are actually that's a great sounds
like an awesome book
i've never
that's a sketch or cartoon so we got two
comedians to make content you can you
can either if you can take it where
people are like it's a banned book club
and the book i bought is playboy but
like they're literally no they're making
the argument for why the book should be
banned too yes what do you mean they
just don't realize it like can you belie
like they're making an argument in favor
of banning books because when you when
you use the phrase book ban it doesn't
really have a positive connotation
there's this book band look what's on it
you're like maybe we should have a book
ban maybe maybe you shouldn't let
children look at everything in schools
it's easy to make your own book now too
so any any psycho can make a book about
crazy stuff get it in under the sensor
radar like amazon you can publish your
own stuff on amazon if you posted these
pictures on instagram they would ban you
yeah well
they would delete the post and give you
a warning yeah well and look at you had
amazon insiders complaining about matt
walsh's book johnny the walrus being
number one
and if i'm not mistaken they were
actually trying to derank that i don't
know about deranking okay they got it
removed from children's okay yeah so
they had to remove from the children
section so that's not acceptable but
showing graphic lewd images as far as we
understand which actually depict minors
is acceptable that is hideously
disgusting is there a way for people to
find this image so they know we're
talking about without actually
all over no yeah i mean if you if you
google i only want to encourage people
to look for it i mean it's like know
thine enemy you do need to know what's
in this book because the way the new
york times is painting is this is they
took a picture that she didn't even put
in the book and they said oh this is
what the artist draws it's like oh mom i
think i might be bi oh that's so sweet
how could republicans possibly want to
ban this if this is actually what's in
the book that's crazy they're just being
mean but that is not what's in the book
and i was so relieved to see that this
tweet that the new york times put out
about this article got freaking ratio
good right to heck because everyone's
like this is what's actually in the book
i was like did you guys put the picture
in the article of course they didn't can
you scroll does it say 18 years and up
yes it does it does indeed what did you
say it says right there 18 years or not
look at that where where exactly is it
uh reading age and the little the the
icons
that
uh no like the the all the row
oh here here yeah
so 18 years and up so why would anyone
complain that it's not allowed in
schools yeah although i think they're
perverts who want to groom kids yeah
it's not really good yeah or they're
ignorant and they're
foot soldiers for a mass movement of
psychosis i've been overusing that word
psychosis i know but i don't i don't
think it's possible to
book and claim ignorance doesn't new
york times dozens of schools pulled it
from library shelves republican
officials in north and south carolina
texas virginia called for the books
removal sometimes labeling it
pornographic okay suddenly kebab was at
the center of a nationwide battle over
which books belong in schools yo amazon
says 18 and up the scandal is that these
were in schools in the first place is
there constantly too like a blue state
red state debate where you know blue
states to go these are the books we
don't think are appropriate and you know
it'll be like
huckleberry finn or something yeah
whatever you know like they just they
kind of go back and forth and they just
it's weird that they have their it's
usually racist and sex but hold on hold
on look if the left this this is the
derangement and the twisted nature of
the activists left
anyone any leftist could come out and
start speaking out against this and be
like this book shouldn't have been in
there we don't see it we see the
defensive we see the new times defense
of it they do come out and talk about
you know huckleberry finn oh it's got
old racist terminology it shouldn't be
in the schools it's racist and
insensitive there was a there was a big
story about a kid who complained because
they had to read the book and the book
uses the n-word and it's just like okay
that's a book which is
contextual history it was written for a
period in during a period and we could
address that critically and talk about
it that's fair this book is literally
labeled 18 and up and depicts sex acts
between
you between people and that shouldn't be
for children yeah and it's just
something some pervert made because they
want to show children and warp them it's
not as if this is something that's part
of america's foundational classical
literature that it would be important
for a kid to know what concerns me is
when someone is warped as a child and
then grows up and warps children the
same way they were warped like the cycle
of abuse you know physical abuse the
kids beat by their parents they grow up
and then they beat their kids i hate to
see the same thing happen with sexual
abuse so i'm not saying that
transgenderism is sexual abuse but i
would be afraid that some of it may be
no no it's the exploitation when people
are abused their minds get pretty crazy
when you have abusers masquerading as
the lgbtq positive whatever
we've seen this they they they try and
sneak it under the radar they make they
make people look bad they make the whole
community look bad but i think the left
is so instinctive to defend any and all
you end up with bad people getting away
with bad things because they'll just
feign being part of some community i
want to mention huckleberry finds in the
library of congress
1876 published
i read like the first third of the book
i remember it was awesome i honestly i'm
trying to think now too i'm like i
honestly think when i was in high school
maybe not maybe elementary school but we
did read it and like you know you read
it out loud and i was like man if you
were that kid who got that page oh watch
out is that the one word damn where huck
was going down the river on the raft
with jim
is that huck and jim on the river yeah
yeah that book's
amazing yeah i mean it's like yeah it's
all the time but yeah it's like if you
especially now
pbs band adventures of huckleberry finn
why is huck finn constantly consistently
landed on the list of banned and
challenged books
because it talks about race and stuff
like that he uses the word but i mean
absolutely but it's in the gym is like
the black guy and they're good friends
huck like has massive respect for the
guy well isn't the pr isn't the point of
the story that like he's belittled for
his race and it's completely unfair yeah
yeah he sees past that like it's such a
good book man such a i didn't finish the
book but it was so cute
it wasn't that good i was 12
material that amazon says is for 18 and
up
just just can we just can i my friends
if ever someone comes to you and they're
like what are you talking about and you
know what's going on and they don't
believe you when you tell them weird
stuff's happening just go to amazon look
up the book genderqueer and say what age
is the recommendation
and uh uh
whoa this just came out yeah
whoa whoa
this just broke right now what let me
just finish that point yeah finish your
point show them the genderqueer thing
show this is this is groundbreaking but
show them the genderqueer thing show
them the banding from schools and show
them the outrage thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there